[Laughter]
greetings in podcast Vil [__]
it's Monday the 10th of February the
church what's happening now is brought
to you by God it
listen supplements to the [__] max
whether it's the Alpha brain the shroom
tech or the shroom tech sport right now
if you're traveling I recommend you see
Asians you pop a [__] shroom tech
immune right now you walk into a Chinese
restaurant you and I am prejudiced I'm
just telling you how I feel they're
[__] leap animal did you see how many
Asians were at the airports that March
them out here [__] Puerto Ricans yeah
reasons bad luck father returned I asked
a woman at my show I said are you what's
the deal with a corona virus she goes
are you asking me because I'm Asian I
said yes no but you're [__] Chinese
that's why I got ya anyway go to
adam.com right now you wanna stay
healthy if you travel you want to stay
healthy if you [__] you want more
energy if you want your mind to work
right half a brain the best in the
business on a button hundred-percent
money-back guarantee and they don't want
the product back put that your [__]
pipe is smoking it right go to Anna
comrade now impress in church and get
10% off you all it delivered right to
your [__] house without further
ado my brother from a different mother
mr. Tim Dylan what's happened thank you
for having me buddy
and the flying Jews here today yeah
special appearance oh thank you fresh
from Israel looking smooth tonight was a
little black t-shirt on
you look like an extra from uncut gems
yeah I'd be pissed and give them a
backhand yeah what's going on nothing
much flew in just flew in from Chicago
[__] great weekend there you know
early show on Saturday one audience
member punched another which is always
good it means there
passionate they're excited yeah but you
know zany's downtown chicago's dark you
can't see what's going on so i did a
joke and and no joke usually does really
well nobody's laughing and I'm hearing
little skirmishes in the crowd I said
what what the [__] happened did I do the
wrong thing a guy and another guy for
whatever reason I don't know how it
happened maybe somebody's interrupting
somebody he just [__] clocked them
and then him and his chick got up and
the guy who did it him and his chick got
up and got out of there the manager I
had to get involved so I just you know I
just kind of plowed through with the set
that's tremendous that's what it is
that's comedy I have a hard time with
xanies downtown yeah you don't like it
no no no like yeah of the club it's they
don't like me there's just some clubs
you're gonna go to oh yeah he is oh yeah
well I don't know if it's
psychologically yeah what's something
you while you're on stage you don't have
a good time and they don't seem to have
a good time yeah I used to be a club in
Baton Rouge Louisiana
they didn't laugh right but after they
all came up to you and hug you and told
ya great yeah I never felt anything like
that in my life
Ryan's different clubs you know Irvine
improv I love the club they just don't
love me right I could do her violin I
feel like I'm losing with every [__]
joke well that yeah Brea
I love Brea Ontario I feel that way
about like the Northeast I know I love I
listen I love the store but I feel like
I am like designed for the Northeast and
for the Midwest a little bit when I get
out here West Coast people are a little
bit more relaxed do a little bit more
laid-back I'm a little darker a little
bit more aggressive I feel like they're
kind of like what's going on you know
see you know be these beach towns
everybody's doing good they're surfing
all day they come in I'm screaming about
you know Disney you know raping your
kids and whatever I'm talking about they
don't get that you know what about the
south are they doing this south you know
I've not been to the south a lot I taped
a Netflix thing years ago in Atlanta
which was good I mean I haven't been to
the South a lot I did some stuff in New
Orleans which is fun I I think this year
I'm gonna be in the South more that I've
ever
Halla we've been doing comedy about 10
years 10 years to 2010 late 2010 when I
was like doing Kali I discovered the
South like in 2001 yeah and I've pretty
much scared the [__] out of them that's
what I hate of entertainment
aka Charlotte yeah I don't love
Charlotte comedy zones yeah I just did
Charlotte Hannah had a string of
one-nighters right there with Tribble
runs only they pay the hundred dollars
more right still dark rooms and I
remember going on and eating [__] every
night yeah I'm [__] Tennessee West
Virginia right I'm going to Zane he's
the first time an opening for Stan
Holmes had it be 2001 and going up there
and having them seven minutes and then
losing them Yanik Chicago or Nashville
Nashville and then watching Stan I'll go
up and he holds him for 14 that's right
and then they'd realized what are we
laughing at with Christians right
alright so I said you know what I hate
dick in Nashville I hate dick in Atlanta
I'm waiting all [__] day to do a
guest set at Charlotte little did I know
it was black night right I walk in there
it's [__] a little Africa I walk into
the spot they look at me like nah yeah I
waited all [__] day at the call you
know there are no money right you got a
suit this is when you set to sit at
Starbucks yeah and [__] take a sip
every hour you know sit and be hydrate
cuz god forbid you finish that coffee
yeah I got a milk that coffee thing it
hours yeah you got a [__] steal a
tuna sandwich from the hotel before I
leave and [__] and now you gotta wait
cuz you're gonna have enough money just
to get the cab the cab is 82 from the
[__] cuz the app what's never close
to the comedy club when you yeah it's
funny it's like being a drug addict
being a comedian it's like very similar
the same thing the same and you lived
the same way we've just accommodate
right just to get just to subsist you
live so once I went to Atlanta I was
done it was like I was too much of a New
Yorker they just and then I wanted
Jacksonville Oh Nellie yeah I did I
cover three me Shubert how to cancel
okay and I probably had 35 and that's if
I tap dance and pull the whistle right
right that's if I pulled the wood block
back that all right seriously yeah I was
living in Seattle I got 30 when I left
Seattle I had 18 because I have 12 you
left local joke right so they disappear
I go boom I came down it with 18 what's
great is when you see people trying to
do local jokes when they forget the
first time go tried like a boss yeah New
York comedians do subway bits in Iowa
people stare at them like what are you
doing oh my god yes what kid wants in
San Diego that I saw him Boston I was
friends with him in Boston at at the
[__] comedy club we do the open mics
on the road was in Boston he had a bit
about the guys on the radio getting
drunk Tommy Heinsohn and tricking
Budweiser and that you know it was just
a brilliant bit if you lived in Boston
right every time he did it if you had to
follow him you were gonna die yeah it
was an eight-minute bit about you know
this [__] two guys there you know he
hit he hit the backboard like a brick
right speaking of break some other toes
for the king of beers yeah yeah wiser
all right just [__] constantly and I
never forget seeing him I saw two people
do that one was this kid in Boston do
that same joke in La Jolla and at the
three minute mark he realized where the
[__] he was and why he was dying that
his life's great and you could see it in
his face tabasco else I saw this happen
- when I first met him circa 2002 sand
Tripoli oh wow Sam Tripoli when I first
met Sam he was opening up for Pablo and
he was doing a whole bit about ecstasy
is some drugs like [__] and I'll never
forget that one night Mitzi just
Mitzi sometimes past you but in the
beginning she didn't know where to put
you
I remember she used to put standoff up
and [__] two chicks out of follow him
yeah and I remember one time he gotta
follow this lesbian check with the
[__] the whole head when I was in
there and it was like an eight o'clock
calmly listen twenty years ago the eight
o'clock show was the mild show the ten
o'clock show was a little bit more
risque little less but he knew that that
was the term uu8 dick for the first show
and some people flipped it some people
like some people hate Friday late yeah a
lot of people complain about Friday Late
Show sucks
I [__] hate it hard to sell it's hard
to hard to sell a Friday Late Show she
put Stanhope up one time I think the
show used to start late dirty and she
put Stanhope up at 8:45 on a Saturday
night
and I saw it and I go I have to go down
and see this I still remember the girl's
name that had a follow him I will not
mention it I don't I remember the second
girl I had a follow but the first girl
was a chubby lesbian okay and she went
up there and they were like in shock she
had like green air and he I still
remembers and grabbing the mic and y'all
keep it go or whatever her name yeah
Shirley MacLaine yeah that's not a
regular lesbian that's a real [__] was
she's got a kids game with a [__] bump
and they were frozen right like in those
days the reports you were hearing about
Stanhope were that he was like just
leveling The Improv what that meant was
even the comics were cracking yeah like
that we're not gonna follow that like
right comics was complaining more buy
them back then but yeah he was causing
such a [__] Rutgers right but what I
saw him cause at the comedy star that
night yeah a special he started with
that about the [__] pump as a softball
kid game that's great he just ran from
that sometimes I I think that's it's fun
to watch that oh it's yeah hilarious
yeah to watch the audience yeah
when they don't know what they signed up
yeah they get shaken out of their
comfort cycle of it yeah I love it yeah
and I love that uncomfortable laughter
when there's I love bombing yeah it is I
don't mind bomb right but I like those
eight people that again does your pee
both of your people yeah bombing yeah
this one guy over here that if you do
this he [__] giggles I'd rather it's
like an outright bomb is good and then
obviously killing is good the worst
thing in the world is when they're
actually having fun but they're not
alive like they're they're in there
they're there but they're not there
because you can't get mad because I lash
out if I'm bombing I lash out at them a
little bit and it's funny to fight with
them but it's you know if they're just
you know one of the shows this weekend
they're all sold out and it's a lot of
fans but one of the shows they were
having fun but not as much fun as I
wanted them to have you see them having
fun they were just not and I and I
couldn't say hey [__] you because they
all bought tickets to see me I just had
to you know do as good as and then after
the show everybody says we loved it it
was great thank you so much let's take a
photo
but like during it didn't have that
electric energy and then the next show
was back to the electric like you know
smash and all that stuff so sometimes
it's just a psychology of that
particular group of people when did you
start doing comments 2010 what made you
get up what made me do it the first time
I was in the mortgage business and in
$2,000 educated no dropped at a
community college to do percocet and
sell subprime mortgages in Long Island
which I still believe is the what I will
return to I believe stand-up is a
sabbatical for my true calling which is
to work in a strip mall and have great
lunches serious lunches and I'd take
percocet and and and telemarket
mortgages in the tri-state area all over
the country but the tri-state area we
hit because you could go and sit down at
the table I have a meeting that I
remember we were in at the Melville
Marriott and there was a CEO of a really
big bank there and he was hammered and
he looked at me and a few young kids not
young we like 24 you know and he said to
us he goes boys there's a cold wind
blowing and he was just coming he was
just knocking back booth you know this
guy had a family at a big house and he
was leveraged you know you know all this
was you know he had you know so he yeah
and I was like looking around the office
and I was like weird we're done
we're dead in the water it's like it's
it's over it's over there's no coming
back from this my life is done and then
I was like it's I'm 25 I'm not educated
what am I gonna do and I walked into a
coffee-house tattoo parlor on Long
Island because one of my friends gave me
the name of an open mic he goes go do
this open mic and see what happened
interesting comedy growing up I mean I
love so I love like you know I would see
Karlin he'd be great I remember once
when I was coming down from shrooms
first year at college somebody showed me
Bill Hicks his set at Montreal I think
it revelations I think a relentless I
forget which one it was where he's in
the black turtleneck and he opens up
because I was for the war he goes we had
a war in the States and he goes I was in
the unenviable position of being for the
war but against the troops and I thought
that was one of the funniest things I'd
ever heard and you coming down from
shrooms you like wait what the [__] that
I even hear that right and I watched
that set and I was really like drawn
into that but I mean he's a kid I I
loved that Sanel I loved all that and I
was an actor from when I was six to when
I was 12
child actor so I was in plays I
auditioned for you know sitcoms in New
York all that [__] so I was like into
theater and stuff like that but nothing
ever worked I was a failed actor at 11
you know but I took that I took a little
break and then 25 I got back in so it
was like I always had that bug wanting
to be onstage wanting attention once you
got one then when you got back on that
tattoo place yes how did you feel when
you got off the stage
I said okay this is where I belong I fit
here I said here I said I fit here which
was insane
she was a tattoo parlor cafe and I said
the place didn't even make sense but
it's Long Island so nothing makes that
like when you would bomb you heard the
needle goes and then somebody getting a
tattoo would go next and then you go to
the next job but it was I said I was
like I I'm just gonna keep coming back
here and I'm gonna follow everybody here
to the next place they go and to the
next place they go and then I can't I
just kept following people and going
where are we doing comedy you know and
that's how I got into it then eventually
that led me to New York and then it led
me you know years and years later to uh
to LA well what'd you get on stage 2010
2010 September 2010 when did you move to
New York I moved to New York two years
after that two years after New Orlean
all in the first two years I was driving
in to New York City and I did a lot of
black rooms cuz black rooms would let
you go up you know a lot of the
alternative rooms they were you know
more selective they were kunti and you
couldn't get in the clubs but black
rooms would let you go up urban urban
shows and and and they liked me I was a
big white guy I was funny and you know
and they were really find my friends
loved going to these rooms because these
guys were killer I mean we'd see my gaps
you know smokey Suarez these guys are
just murderers all my a you know Mike
some of my friends would come with me
and then when I went to the city I
started doing the alternative rooms and
you know girls would get up and open a
moleskin book my friends stopped coming
they were like we've had enough of this
but that's what I did primarily flecked
the first two years was open mikes and
then I would do you know black rooms and
in in Brooklyn and in the Bronx and and
then I would do you know whatever you
got you get a club spot here you get a
club spot there but then I moved in 2012
right before Hurricane sandy and I moved
in with a married couple and their
marriage they were just getting married
and that didn't last that marriage that
was the second divorce I was maybe a
part of first was my parents the second
one was
I probably share some blame for both of
them cuz nobody wants a 25 year old guy
like me moving in with you when you just
get married it's just not what it it you
know that's not nobody want nobody move
on we're friends of your dad a cheap
room five hundred dollars Imran yeah and
they were comics and they go five
hundred a month listen the building was
built in 1911
it's a railroad apartment it's a long
hallway and your rooms on one end our
rooms on the other the shower is in the
kitchen so somebody's gonna be washing
their ass somebody's gonna be making
eggs and the bathroom is in the hall of
the building but it's on 45th between
8th and 9th Avenue you got every subway
in the city you have a rooftop you could
go up and smoke cigarettes and tell your
friends how [__] good you did at the
open mic which I you know would do all
the time and they go you can live here
five hundred dollars a month so I said
done deal
in so that's when I went that's why I
would consider all in because then
you're living in that situation you
living with steam heat and you know
you're 25 you're 27 at that point I'm 27
I'm not I'm by no means a kid and I'm
you know waking up every day you know
because my foot touches the steam pipe
and you know yet so you get a
third-degree burn and then you're
rolling out of bed and that's when I was
doing comedy every night and then during
the day trying to sell photo copiers in
Staten Island yeah it's a it's a it's
photocopies the jobs get said oh no if
jobs get said but I'm a sales like I
myself I'm [__] me through I'm full
of [__] and I always I'm with people
that are always also full of [__] my
father's full of [__] my grandfather
wasn't he was a contractor he worked you
know he was real worked with his hands
buildings man you're not full of [__]
you have the gift of gab well I like to
what you say there's a big difference
right that's a good difference and being
foolish [__] right and being a gift of
gab right okay the gift of gab is you
could just talk to people yeah make them
yes sell them a prize yeah sell them a
product
yeah that they don't need yes that they
don't need and shouldn't have okay
whether it's you know when here's a
funny thing
what we do is comics when we realize
that sales goes into it that
and everything changes in our game right
that's true in sales gets into it you
could be the best commune in the world
you're not selling yourself you're done
you find it's so weird
how my background in sales was
impeccable
yeah well I've been into sales I fell in
love with it because I was uneducated
right I was GED yeah and I knew I didn't
want there was one thing there was a
couple things I knew early on a I didn't
want a date job
we're at just was not gonna work right a
world and number two I didn't want to
[__] work for a certain wage every
hour right I wanted us never have a
ceiling that always made sense to me
yeah what does that mean the Euro
salesman yeah that's exactly right some
once you're gonna make 800 bucks and you
suck it the [__] up let me make a grand
and some munch you make a grand yeah
suck it the [__] up right and somewhere
and then you learn how to balance that
you learn right away the first month you
make eight grand a steak house you got a
porterhouse for two okay you got a
shellfish tower Lobster books I'm here
it's a blue claw crab on that two please
thank you very much let's get a couple
of gin martinis let's do the cheesecake
bring all the appetizers lobster bisque
port and cups will drink it what we need
to stay and then it's like then you have
then then you realize you have to pay
taxes because sales is the 1099 they
give you a crane you didn't make eight
grand by the way you know Oh money so I
would get a check and then I would go
out and spend money and then I'd realize
oh I owe money like I owe four thousand
attack goes to the government and I
didn't pay any of it so that was
something too but when I got into comedy
the only job I could get was in Staten
Island and it was photo copiers and and
selling office equipment sad because
when you're selling real estate of
mortgages at least somebody around
you've got a lot of money and you could
look at them and be like well I want to
be that I want to be you know my boss
this guy Tim or the big house in a pool
but when you when you telemarketing
photocopies Staten Island everybody
there is desperate and they all have
that job because it's in walking
distance of their house where they can
take a bus many of them just had D
weezing bus after them a halfway house
is right
they're alcoholics yeah
hospitals telemarketing yeah house HBO
yeah hasn't developed a show pitch for
about yeah well telemarketers I know six
people who were [__] serious life and
six people who live day to day to day
shoot heroin right they [__] they got
HIV but part of the sales plan is cash
yes okay so there's jobs that like I had
a great [__] job I got a job at night
well I did calm me right before I left
for New York I got a job from five to
nine yeah he's perfect I have to nine
tell those are the those are the prime
time bucks hours to pound the phone
found the phone found the father think
it was ten an hour yeah I Commission
plus Commission twenty five an
appointment yeah your appointment center
he was much assurance guy right I just
get him in the door he had a sheep that
he already had contact of course and it
was well that's department I would try
to get three appointments in our yeah
you get three appointments out that's 75
that's [__] you know three four
hundred a night yeah what a box yeah I
used to sell us a good moon cigars Bobby
and the 90s a micro here yeah when I
became a regular at the store the
biggest job in LA was selling cigars on
the hop sunset right across from
rock'n'roll route yeah where the hotel
is walk 50 steps that building there
were 20 [__] [__] in there
ten of us were you know actors common
yeah you had to be there at six five in
the morning five or six the morning but
the other ten were [__] people who
were toothless degenerate [__] drinkin
while they were [__] five in the
morning
who was the barracks house drinking
there was listen anybody can have a good
day yeah I got the best salesmen sons of
[__] was a woman in the end of copy
office it was a woman named Ida they go
Ida just shots appointments they said
sit next
if you train you sit next to the top
producer when you train so you sit next
to Ida and this was the top producer at
this still and she looked at me I'll
never forget this because she's puts in
perspective how [__] everybody was she
goes I'm doing good this year and if I
do even better I'm gonna get a car and I
went oh [__] she's the top
she's Mount Olympus and she doesn't have
a [__] car
I said she doesn't have a car and she
would get on a bus every single day and
she said three or four appointments get
on the bus every day make her make her
money make her money make her money and
that's what she was she was just she was
just a you know she had the gift of gab
we got the gift of gab they can't you
always eat yeah I always say well what's
the best motivator hunger yeah who's the
best hungriest kindness yeah there's
some cool about a sales office too
because it is a level playing field
every day every day you start around to
tremendous yet gift yeah see somebody
yeah but you started every morning at
8:00 nobody cares white Spanish gay
straight Asian no it's about making
money it's about numbers on a boardwalk
in line yeah you realized what the
bottom line is of life yeah I tell
people a lot of listeners people were
very intelligent life but if I [__]
woke you up today and gave you a [__]
gun and said have five hundred by five
o'clock every day you this is how the
life I lived yeah you know was yeah
James for me yeah I left at eight I
didn't know what I was bumping and a lot
of people that have never had to do that
with dangerous college or whatever and
they just got you know certificates and
degrees and they got licenses and they
just their entire life was just a
different track but there's something
about having nothing because when you're
in one of those offices you're
telemarketing nobody cares but if you
come in they don't care if you come in
nobody's there's nobody's gonna call you
and go hey are you supposed to be here
they might do that one day they assume
you're not gonna come they assume you're
not gonna show up there is no they don't
give a [__] because somebody's gonna sit
in that seat if you don't it's an
enticing tire
on you there's nobody there that has any
investment in what you're doing you're
the only one now while you were doing
all this [__] yes that Milan yeah and
four people don't know Staten Island
that was all so yeah but you know you
leaving 45th Street Manhattan yeah to
take a trainer yeah well I was taken I
was taking up I was taking up in the
beginning I was taking a subway to a
boat to a ferry oh my god
and then the ferry to a bus and I would
take a 40 minute bus ride down to the
end of Staten Island School Tottenville
which was the end of Staten Island
almost by Jersey by the Bayonne Bridge
so I would go down there to reliable
office systems I was told that I was you
know everybody I would steal cereal this
[__] would bring in Special K red berry
cereal and I would steal a little cup of
it and I would down it and I mean in
like a minute down it would milk a
minute just steal a cereal and then go
in and sit next to Ida and just pound
the phone and try to set appointments
three months into that I was said enough
appointments here like you're good at
this you got to come to our City office
which was by Bryant Park Madison Avenue
and I'll call me al brought me an owl
was the head of that office from Long
Island and Al goes you're gonna come
here now you gotta remember do a comedy
at night and that's my main focus so al
brings me and then he goes he goes
you're gonna you're gonna be good at
this it's gonna be your career he said
this to me now obviously you know listen
anybody else would love to hear that I
hated that I hated that he said that to
me as I was sitting in this office and I
couldn't tell him I'm gonna be in
committee a go yeah yeah yeah he's a
Long Island Iced again yeah me too we're
all gonna be comedians shut up here's
what you're gonna do you're gonna sell
these can and copier you know and that
guy he was just a good salesman like
he's so canon and all he would say is on
the phone it's a good machine it's a
good machine that was his thing people
it's very expensive because a good
machine though it's good good machine
right am i right
people go yeah yeah I guess it is and he
was just like one of these guys who they
hired me in the city so I started doing
it in the city and I started now I had
no clothes I had like a suit that didn't
fit like an ill-fitting suit I'm 300
pounds to suit doesn't fit my guts
hanging out I have like that shirt it's
half in half out
I have shoes that are basically
moccasins that I'm passing off as dress
shoes because I have no [__] money
and he sells guys they don't understand
that and and I'm and I'm walking around
walking in hedge funds I'm walking in a
law office they think I'm homeless they
think the people like wait well
secretaries are trying to stop me I'm
like no no I'm trying to sell you copier
I sold a few of them like set B just
because I'm a fun guy and I'd walk in
and they'd be like who's this [__]
lunatic somebody came up to me one sec
all your things great you walk in like a
mess people take notice of you it's not
my thing I have no money they go you
think what you do is good you wear
ridiculous shoes your shirts got bird
[__] on it it's great they go this is
like uh tickle this is like a [__]
thing you know they thought it was a
thing they're like yeah this is it's
just good you're like a slob and people
but but you know the you know you
memorize the pamphlet you could make
people laugh so I sold a few of these
things but the problem was now you're
starting to do good now they're like why
don't you come out to dinner why don't
you meet this guy one and then the
problem is like what I gotta do open
mics I'm not even on shows yet so I got
to do open mics like 6 7 p.m. I can't
even do things at 8:00 or 9:00 p.m. yeah
so eventually I quit that job cuz I was
like I gotta get out of the sales world
which I had been in since I was 22 21
really I had been in sales and then I
left it when I was like 28 I just
brought it off just mortgages and the
copiers it always been in sales and then
the only job all right so guys I got a
tour bus and they were just yelling at
tourists on a bus that was going through
Times Square and now I was like well
that guy can't have a boss they can't be
any background check to do that job
symbaloo these tour guides in New York
they were lunatics these people you know
one woman I swear to God would just go
on and talk about a knee operation and
the people and they were trying to learn
about the Empire State Building she
would say she would he or she go I've
had nine operations on the same foot
people would and put people with
different yeah it was a good you know
she was an animal but people felt bad
for her so they
so they fill the tip cup up at the end
so it's like oh these people are also in
their own way con artist degenerates
marginalized figures from society you
know some of them thought they were
historians some of them they were awful
ship you know these guys they barely
knew anything I was just like I'll go up
there and make my whole goal was like
I'll make everybody laugh so I would you
know pass a building I'd be like what
the [__] going on in there you know
I'm like you know I was like you know
you make him doing that 15 an hour 15 an
hour but checks so that's bad so I know
so I 40-hour work weeks I never left
with a check over 350 okay but cash tips
every day of either no money when I was
lazy and didn't want to give the tour
and a Russian woman punched me in the
stomach once because we were sitting on
the thing it was jad first of all all
the Russians are poor they come in
january/february they have no [__]
money there they're poor they come the
coldest time of the year and then what
you'd have to do a tour for one Russian
couple and the thing with Russians is
their beautiful blue eyes like Huskies
but they have no souls
so when you see cuz they have a hundred
years of atheism so they have no salt so
there's nothing you know so when you
look in their face you see there's
nothing there so I just sat on the bus
and this Russian woman said to me she
goes you'll give tour you fat [__] I
said listen to the automated tour I said
I'm not doing it today you the only
people on the bus she goes you get I pay
money you give tour you give tour I said
no you cuz I could put it on the
automated when I was being lazy and the
automated would be like and the
automated was supposed to be hooking but
a GPS but it was never where it should
be so we'd be by a central park and
they'd be like you are seeing the 9/11
Memorial and everybody would look out
like where's 9/11 you know they had no
idea cuz the GP these companies don't
care because these buses there's no
repeat business you just you you can get
your Bangor bill Burt it has a great
thing where he talks about the guys who
sell tickets to these buses they're all
Africans and Haitians and they all have
deep machete scars in their faces
they make eight or nine grand a month
and they send that all back to Africa I
think Burt I haven't heard a bit but
Burt somebody told me the bar either
talks about it on a podcaster did it
does a bit about it but they're they're
aggressive salesmen they'll fight each
other in the street and then once the
tickets are sold it's over
you're not gonna complain about this
what are you gonna go find the office
and complain about what I said or did
who gives a [__] so if I was feeling
lazy but if I was really killing it I
could walk off the bus with 200 bucks in
cash if I was really killing it like
pizza here cheesecake here here's the
best steak she was the great sandwich
here's the best blocks to walk you want
to see mansions you know I could kill it
if I wanted to and then a Russian woman
you know she was she had it so she got
up and her boyfriend this was hilarious
her boyfriend cuz I guess she hit him
too he didn't even he wasn't even like
present it's the thing with certain
Russian people like he just sat there
frozen like he was dead and she got up
and she goes you give tour and just
shocked me in the stomach
hard hard like hard you know it's kind
of demoralizing so I had to pick up the
[__] microphone now and be like all
right this is the Dakota where John
Lennon lived you [__] [__] you know
and then I gave the tour for the rest of
the press like Greg Chapman's you would
doing stand-up yeah we would stand up on
a bus do a stand-up comedy on a bus all
day Shane whatever the hell I want
getting some complaints but my boss
didn't care cuz he doesn't give a [__]
how many towards the day two to three
tours a day it was brutal so in the heat
it was brutal cuz it's a metal boss and
everybody gets up there and everybody's
pouring sweat and people because New
York's not a pleasant city - Vince
beautiful it's amazing it's three it's
the greatest city in the world but it's
not a relaxing vacation so you're
dealing with people that are like
they're all stressed out because they
got a Broadway show they got to get to
they get this ticket that they want to
see the Statue of Liberty they want to
go up in a helicopter they want to do 90
all these fat people from Ohio they want
to see Central Park but they don't want
to walk through it they're like how do i
what do we do I can't walk through so
you know so they won't go into subway
they think everybody's gonna stab you
with an AIDS needle and I'm like the
subway is safer than up here right now
you know go down there save for the you
know
and they she deal with all those people
I would just make him laugh every day
and then do spots at night so that was
the job and then once I started getting
a little bit going I did the Montreal
Comedy Festival 2016 I took the bus out
I sold tickets and did it for the New
York Comedy Festival and people bought
tickets and I just did like a crazy tour
in New York and just basically said this
was my [__] life and then fans of
like my podcast [__] got to sit on the
bus and see what I used to do and it was
hilarious you know cuz I would talk
about like human trafficking and drugs
and and you know my roommates and you
know everybody on Broadway I dig all its
must be amazing to be a Broadway I said
these people are all one broken ankle
away from living on the street
then you see a college still like a high
school theater group would come and your
face is with God I said they don't make
any money I said I know the woman of
Phantom of the Opera
she drinks soup out of a cup and stares
at the rain and the Food Emporium I said
every day she wants to put a gun in her
mouth I said so let me tell you I said
and if she falls in sprained her ankle
she's gonna be living in the street and
she's gonna go have to go to his suburbs
and [__] her way to the middle class and
then she's gonna have to work at your
school which I thought was funny and but
it's one of the kids started crying one
of the but I'm like this is what it is
this is what life is and that was like
my tour and that wasn't for everybody
you know I learned a big lesson last
year I had to go to New York and spend
18 days to shoot a movie and I didn't
you know I grew up on 88th Street right
I was [__] 4050 years you know I left
New York in 83 that was a long [__]
time yeah you know in my mind I wish it
was still the same New York right so I
don't know where to stay right they told
me you're gonna be picked up on 36th and
third everyday yeah dad so I figure let
me get a hotel closed today I don't want
to stay in Jersey have to come over the
fan right right you know and though I
made a mistake
I still I stay at the hotel
where all that [__] goes down yeah the
the [__] black guy with the ax someone
yeah where did you remember where he
stayed I'd rather not say Oh guys I
think I'll give me a rate there were
nice people but I had to leave
yeah I had to leave yeah that area and I
would work out a Dangerfield's and
haven't been saying that New York before
you go to New York you never to take a
tour is no class yeah like you have to
go somewhere like before you go to New
York yeah you gotta do a little you
gotta do something yeah like and I came
it like even Chicago's too big for you
right but let's start somewhere small
and write yourself up yeah you cannot be
a [__] idiot
hey I saw a lot like I made the mistake
and stayed I was there for three weeks
the first hotel was a cool hotel but a
bit too cool for Uncle Joe right yeah I
hate those hotel sit to cool people
drinking upstairs right no room service
the breakfast was English you know yes I
want lamb chops for breakfast no let you
know I want to [__] [__] ride a war
little too the rooms cold you know the
room was cool okay I had a [__] I
couldn't find any way to eat New York
City walk five blocks finally I found
the diner and added a cool little Greek
time yeah yeah yeah second week I stayed
in the heart right by the garden that
was the biggest mistake yeah Walt that's
a problem over there oh my god getting
in and out of there was a nightmare I'm
yeah I'm nights that the hotel i-10
elevators yeah that's how many people
were staying in every time you got in
the elevators you thought you were in
Las Vegas people often forget about now
with the colonel yeah I always forget
about well people New York gets 50
million tourists every year think of
that it's is crazy 50 to 60 million
every year they come in and they come in
primarily from
July through December that's the big
that's the so it's sandwiched in to and
then you didn't January February you get
a little break January February March a
little break huh
yeah but then what's April May starts
they start ramping up again and once you
get to July forget it I mean and I
worked in Times Square and I remember
what it felt like to get up every
morning and then have to go into Times
Square and be standing with a cup of
coffee on you know 50th and 7th with a
tour bus to tour buses and a line of
people with tickets all these Pete and I
never check tickets they used to get mad
at me they used to go you gotta check
these people's take I go I don't give a
[__] they could be showing me anything
they want to ride the bus they're gonna
ride the bus I'm saying nobody wants to
do this nobody's getting on these for
free I the explain this to the people on
the company I go nobody wants to do this
[__] except these idiots trust me
it's nobody none of my friends are
getting on nobody's getting the better
of me
they all have [__] ticket and he's
like well some of them abused and he can
ride for an extra day it's like buddy
who gives a [__] so I never check
anybody's tickets but you would have to
get them in the bus they were hot it was
disgusting there was no bathroom on the
bus people will come up to you you know
Arab guys who come up you always try to
make deals ago you want to pull over I
get cafe for you I get to cafe phone my
wife I get cafe for mango we can't we're
on a tour bus we can't pull over for you
to get coffee for your wife like this is
crate you know but it was just that area
of New York is is is like I liked it and
now I now I go back to it and I go I I'm
in it for a few minutes ago okay but it
was something about it that gave you
energy if you didn't have it like if you
needed energy it was a drug it was a
straight shot of adrenaline every single
day main line and I would get I do two
or three mics and then eventually shows
every night and I was like awake and I
could do it I was like I'm sucking all
the energy out of the city because
that's that that's the center of energy
in the city is that area yeah that area
just just I feel bad for like I was
never a [__] tourist right like I
would never let myself be a [__]
tourist right like never ever
yeah like my wife tried to be when I
took that New York the first time yeah
and I had to cut the legs off for that
[__] what was she trying to do
like just dumb [__] yeah [__] that even
if you live in New York you don't go
there right right when you when you grow
up in New York the first year take it to
the Museum of Natural History right so
you can't take it no more yeah look at
that [__] whale Radio City right yeah
and you go to the [__] Empire State
Building yeah you know that was it I
haven't been in a museum in actually my
dream since I'm you know no7 like the
museum of natural we went to that one we
went to the met yeah I took the girls to
the man I took him there but none of
this [__] will never occur yeah like I
love I usually tell people go bad go eat
I would say go eat I say you learn more
about a city from restaurants
then you will from all this tourist [__]
that you do you're gonna see Museum
you're gonna see artifacts and then who
cares I'm gonna tell you you're gonna go
to a cool restaurant
you're gonna look around watch people
see what they do hang out drink a cup of
coffee sit on a bench just watch it
happen you're gonna get more of an idea
of what the city is then going on some
guided tour you and I just die like a
[__] yeah people play this we
gentlemen and got shot in the head
yeah just Rorschach you in the [__] I
think this is what [__] yovanna made
that drug deal yeah the chick in the
back she's a real New York he oh it's
gone this is the real New York I used to
you know that's what I want to take this
is what [__] my friend Louis yeah and
[__] he puked and we left me a
[__] for dead but that's what I want
to hear if I go to a city that's what I
want to hear you know and I would tell
you know what I would do to cuz the
apartments in New York City is so
expensive I try to make everybody on the
bus feel kind of bad I just pointed to
buildings and I go 10 million 20 million
30 million 35 40 million and everybody
would just get beaten down you know by
the end of the day they realized that
they were [__] they're like God
system's rigged we're all shot you know
and then every now and then one of these
fat broads would try to like even the
scale she go but they don't even have
central air in those buildings
they have wall unit air conditioners now
go but they do have central air in their
Hamptons estates they take helicopters
and land and I'm gonna say don't want to
be a traffic Lennie's up in twenty
thirty thousand square feet and she
would go ah and it was basically me
going like I know you're trying to get
one up on me but not today Pig not today
and I would just make them feel I want
their spirits broken by the time they
left the bus I wanted them to realize
that they had failed and it was nothing
that they could [__] they [__] they
should've did you know that this is you
can't understand they say because New
York is a city that requires both less
and more explanation than any other
place on the planet bit less explanation
meaning you get kind of what it is
immediately but more explains because
I'm gonna point to a building I'm gonna
Teddy average price is twenty six
million dollars I'm gonna say who the
[__] lives there and I'm gonna say
Louise crane lives there her family owns
the paper that we print our money on you
didn't even know that was the thing she
owns [__] money you don't even know
what and in people's minds would melt
you know and that's the type of should I
do and I go and next to her is it
Russian fertilizer magnate and next to
him is a Chinese amusement park tycoon
and then the rest is Jews but here's the
weather and and I would just do that and
some people would love it some people
get off the bus and go man I took two of
these buses and these [__] are
talking about like you know nothing
they're talking about nothing that's
ever effect you know they're talking
about this where George Washington was
and here's where the Redcoats and then
they go you get on here you're talking
about real [__] that's actually
happening and they're like this is
interesting
you know I want to know what's going on
so some people like to but yeah we
should do it will rent the bus to the
Dylan Diaz Diaz Dilan boy I still
remember like being in the 8th grade
being in Jersey and they took this to
Philly to see like them that cracker
sweet yeah and the cracker and Betsy
Ross's house yeah
but you got to do all that yeah I'll
never forget that we went somewhere and
the guy said Santa Cruz Betsy Ross's
house do you know what happened to here
I want my buddies like who gives me just
because those two people yeah like it's
you're so into it
this so into it it's so sad and you
could just throw the ball there's
nothing worse because when I was doing
that job I was doing it as like a means
to an end you know and then there were
people there without was there for
Maggie oh my god that's [__] rough
man I want to take you guys to Boston
because I that's college I went to is
right down by the common and they have
these walking tours but they make the
tour guides dress up like their George
Washington you see that I wouldn't do
that that's when it gets to my like I
listen I barely wore my uniform
Boston's got those stupid Duck Tours
yeah they were excited that the deal
like the but the thing goes in the river
too I'm like that impresses you we blow
up things with a satellite a guy and his
phone and sends drones straight like but
yeah it was but it's sad cuz every job
you have is a comic every shitty job
you're doing it on your way to hopefully
something else but the guy next to you
that's his that's it I used to take a
bus with this guy great guy big guy
lived in Staten Island and he worked in
two telemarketing thing to me it was
good telemarketer but that was that was
it you go oh yeah he doing comedy yeah
yeah that's cool whatever but this was
his thing you know he had a girl and
they would just [__] it he would do and
it's just like guy like that like you
know it's a rough road man it's a rough
road no insurance no savings of money
just trying to scratch up deals to make
a living and it's tough and then also
know they're like no future that you're
looking towards like hey if I go through
all this I'll get here because like you
said it's everyday started zero takes a
very long time to build to where you're
starting at five that takes a couple
years to just build up to where you
started like okay I got a car I got our
department
so it's tough a lot of those people I
met it's like you wonder where they are
now you know when did you start getting
out in New York physically attractive
not hasn't happened yet but we think
2040 is when we're gonna see no when did
things start to work out in in 2016 I
did the Montreal Comedy Festival I had a
good set really good set that was one of
the nights where it just went well it
just everything that could have went it
just went the way it should have went
and it was a big was a big moment in the
sense that like nobody you know no adman
manager ate like my item manager then
but like I didn't have an agent I wasn't
on the road I was doing little things I
was taking mega buses to go do bar shows
and in restaurants and things like that
2016 I got an agent it W me and they
were like okay and I'm like hey I want
to do comedy clubs I want to work on the
road I want to make money to do comedy
that's my main goal yeah I'd love a TV
show I'd love everything else
I'll work hard for that but if you could
get me on the road and make make money
I'll make these people laugh and I think
my first gig was The Improv in San
Antonio which was like a 400-seat room
and I think 13 people came in on a
Friday to see me or Thursday Thursday
show I think 13 people came in was a
kiddin
in a mall you know first fourth floor
and it was like the guy said to me and
it's a big room he goes we got nine
people he goes we don't really do show
until we get 11 so at that point I'm
like you know I mean I might just call
this thing
I'll just go eat a [__] burrito the
size of a car and go to sleep
you know and then the guy comes back in
the green room to manager and he goes
listen because I got good news and I my
I bet it's not he goes another couple
walked in said I had to do you know I
did a show but I did it wait good that
was my first weekend and I just kept you
know my you know and then I did a Comedy
Central thing and in a Netflix staying
at 50 minute you're a half-hour comedy
central 15 minutes of Netflix but it was
it started with with the J I thought I
know everybody says if that festival
doesn't matter anymore and I guess it
does it I mean it's not in terms of like
I know a lot of people that never did it
that are doing great better than me then
there's but for me personally that had
an effect Tim one thing yeah The Tonight
Show doesn't work anymore
right a Showtime special right an HBO
special doesn't work anymore
there's a thousand things that are never
gonna work unless you but if you figure
out how to make them work then they work
then they work great point great point
nobody is ever prepared for we all we
all make mistakes with our goals we God
I can't wait on that line and I can't
wait til I get a Netflix special what
you prepare for is what you gonna do
with that Netflix special I know Haiti
[__] I got enough expense right
and they're still on ships right now
cruise ships they could be on a [__]
cuban missile ship and thank you from
[__] cuban in new york you know what
I'm saying is that nobody really knows
you have to be fully involved fully
engaged and take every opportunity like
it's you're asking yeah you know when
I'd say to you eight Tim you know yeah
come down to the improv I'm doing
something Friday give a bunch of bucks
and walking there nonchalantly and you
walk offstage and some lady comes up to
you and says we've been trying to cast a
show on the after last six years
you are right and you know like Jesus
Joey only knows how close I was to
canceling yeah that's true like how
close I came to order in that grand oh
yeah staying home and getting my dick
sucked but I went out and yeah people
don't understand that it's like you get
these appetizer member the first comedy
and I the first time right before I did
it I go should I just put this off maybe
I'm not ready
maybe I'll do it next week and then I
just said [__] I'm gonna do it and
then it's like that was one of those
moments from like if I put it off then
maybe I never would have done it
let me tell you what happened to me
telling some people the home jfl is just
the last right it's a Montreal Comedy
Festival it's the most prestigious
festival you could be invited to in the
country and what what Tim Dylan was
saying and what's going on is that 20
years ago you went up there
and ten people walked away with a half a
million in cash yeah another ten walked
away with 200,000 in cash yeah another
ten walked away with $50,000 in a
developmental deal which meant that they
were going to develop some type of
reality show show around you the
network's got hit
they gave millions of dollars away to
the wrong [__] people right and that
business went down to two right these
agencies and these management companies
started playing games yeah I'm making up
stories about Lee saiad he's gonna
destroy and then MBC gives Leafs I had a
half million dollar kids got seven
minutes right now the manager has to
pull Lisa other side as well
do me a favor stay out of the three
clubs right what are you talking about
but I just got a half a million not
listen stay on that's really kind of
leaf oh yeah you don't want to be
bombing off in Oxnard as long as you can
as a matter of fact you kidding you can
you imagine tricking somebody so your
manager comes to you and says like in a
way like you we don't want the network's
the big three to see you what they're
telling you is you suck yeah you would
deal because we lie so go up there and
hide before you [__] lose it yeah and
you have to like you have to [__] so
here you have this money in the bank now
and you got to hide because you tricked
everybody you did your best 30 [__]
minutes and now they're bringing people
to see you and they're bringing our
writers and your eating dog [__] so now
that goes the deal so now what happens
you got a deal and went to sour your
with a good manager or a good agent so
now when people look at your they gonna
go what are we gonna do it right he
already got a deal yeah with this agency
so eventually they just know you're 28
yeah yeah and then they just stop giving
everybody the money then they said just
to try it out
they just dried up that's a now that's
what people mean there's no money and
it's the money yeah there's no Muslim
money I had
I you know it was one of those things
where it's it you're it's the first
thing you do with teeth that was the
first thing I did right teeth absolutely
right so the first I was [__] walking
around jfl I was looking at people I'm
looking at people people like your name
I think was up there that you're like
I'm looking at guys and I'm like these
[__] people are working cop these
guys get paid to do this for a living
there's no day jobs there's no [__]
they got fan-based people come to see
them you know and then it's like and
you're looking and you're like I'm gonna
be in a rout like these guys and me are
at the same thing even though we're not
in the same place worth the same
festival you know and you're like I hope
this doesn't go bad and I thought you
know for some people who went bad when
it said to seek so a lot of people got
picked I got picked you know seven years
in the comedy and I'd been doing it
every night there were some people that
got picked two years in all right
because they were queued and they had a
thing and they were yeah I saw a few of
them but it was rough and they make you
fall like the old one yeah so people go
out there and dance you know and then
they did you know these are like monster
girl people might roll the people that
go to that festival they're somewhat
savvy comedic Lee they've seen comedy
they kind of dare they could be good
audiences they could be a little rough
but you you there they're not gonna do
like [__] and so a lot of people
went out there and they just were trying
to stretch their thing it didn't work
and then you just see people that had
some real rough and then it's rough I
remember one guy walked up stage I said
hey good job man and he goes no it
wasn't you [__] know it was it I was
like oh I fell back cuz he was right and
I shouldn't have said that but I didn't
know what to say
okay good set man he's like no it wasn't
he's like you know it was it I was like
uh-huh
I felt bad you know is what it is you
know but again this was a good-looking
just good-looking guy who just clicked
checked all the boxes and went up there
and he had a rough time but I went up
there and I had a joke and I remember
when I broke a moose on my second row
got a joke about pop of the show
Undercover Boss and I was always saying
these [__] D
in CEOs going to cover like [__] with
their employee like it's not enough you
work at a shitty job you got have your
boss make it you know [__] what you want
television and like and then I was like
and then I was like and I think I
stopped in the middle of my joke and I
said I mean the CEOs I said not network
industry CEOs I say you people are good
people
you know I said everybody not in this
room not you guys but the other people I
there and I just started to be me like I
broke out of the joke a little bit and I
just started to [__] around with them
they won't and that's who they were and
and that was so then as soon as that
worked then the rest of the set was
confidence like okay I'm just gonna do
what I do in a bar in the Lower East
Side of Manhattan when I don't care and
it just was it was it just went really
really well really my god
you've done great for yourself I mean
you've uh and you've made the right move
was calculated moves yeah I love when
people come out here dry yeah yeah what
do you want from me right yeah I'm out
here Drive what is dry mean Joey came
out uh I'm nothing yeah yeah well you
know you came out yeah I was what I came
out and all that
I met my producer my collaborator this
guy Ben Avery who makes we were sitting
in his garage one day and we were like
what can we do that's funny because
you'd come out here you don't get spots
immediately she just doesn't have you
know you get a spot you drive to Irvine
you tried to pick his feel I did all
that you know you go to in and out on
the way back on the way there you're
gonna talk about on the way back you do
what you have to do to you know the the
Covina you go here in there but you know
there's not a lot of spots so we just
started making these videos these fun
YouTube videos they would put on
Instagram atwitter where I would just
say wild [__] you know and it would just
you know like the the week Roseanne got
cancelled I said I'll be Roseanne you
know I'll be fat and racist and eat
dinner I'm like what's that show even
about she's fat and she ate dinner it's
all [__] Cho I'll do that you know
and then we just started making these
videos and then we would go and we would
take this desk it would put a desk in
front of like Charlie Baker
and he would film me and it's just like
we were having a ton of fun doing
wonderful of the wall yeah well yeah the
pink wall all these Instagram people and
it was just a way to kind of get funny
out there without waiting for somebody
to call me and go can you come to the
improv at 8 o'clock you know which which
happens now you know but it's Munir the
beginning and then I started just coming
out here so much that when I went back
to New York and felt like I'm on a
vacation cuz you know I wasn't doing the
videos in you I would do anything in New
York I was you know do a stand-up until
my podcast problem I call when I come to
LA we can make these videos we can do
this crazy [__] that's really funny and
and it was you know that was really
really helpful and so that what I did
when I did Rogen wouldn't when I did Joe
show I had some work where people could
look at it and because it would be like
you know we had a great conversation
he's like people were like who is this
guy and you could go to my stuff and
they would go this this is this guy's a
lunatic and he's funny and I like that
he's out here so that that was great
that I did I did and I get obviously
Joe's been amazing and she shared those
things and everything but that's been
just trying to keep up with like all
right so we got to be funny on Instagram
now we just got it so we got to be funny
here that's okay think of what you guys
have that I didn't have right right okay
when I came out here in 98 you waited
for commercial auditions and you waited
for theatrical addition right that's
what you did all day and if not you met
three guys that it's now a Hindu place
right it used to be a Chinese place
right across from rock and roll Ralph's
yeah next to the laundry man the Russian
market needs to be a Chinese place we
used to take over the room nine of us
yeah and we'd throw ideas off each other
that was then now you don't have to have
a boring day right you could make a
video you can go do something you go do
something crazy a bad day you can
schedule a podcast at 1:00 you can add
your podcast at 3:00 you know if you
have dead time there's so many and you
and they're all going towards the same
goal and you could do it listen you
could do a podcast a big YouTube guy was
talking about comic in New York you're
the -
got to do this guy's podcast when you
come to town he's a YouTube guy and the
kaga guy said to me cuz I'm not doing a
youtubers podcast and I'm like you
stupid you're stupid man I don't
understand why cuz that's the other
thing I love about LA I did look you
know Logan Paul's podcast me and Logan
Paul's nothing in common
he's a nice guy he's a fun guy we had a
great time I met him on Theo von show I
got fans from doing it he's a good dude
I like the guy why why ever put yourself
in like a box and I Love New York to
death but I think sometimes guys in New
York you're obsessed with the purity of
it and I'm just gonna do stand-up and
I'm gonna stand you on the stage until
I'm dead and it's like no you gotta you
gotta go out there realize it like yeah
other there's other people out there
there's other mediums out there you
might not like what they do who gives a
[__] oh [__] who gives a [__] to give
you the opportunity they give you an
opportunity you have audiences and what
happened was New York used to think they
were the [__] la has Latin New York and
only in comedy by the way let's not get
any I'm not talking city to city let's
not get excited you know but in comedy
LA because they were first with the pod
casting they were they went big with
that they understood that and and you
know more about that to me maybe it was
because it was less station I don't know
but New York guys now look at LA and
like these I'm gonna be honest I might
get in trouble right now for saying it
the greatest comics in the country right
now are in LA right now not not always
right now the guys that are the best and
the guys that are coming up and are kind
of paving the way are in Los Angeles
right at this moment that's crazy but
the best restaurants are in [__] New
York don't [__] with me on that these
restaurants here should be burned to the
ground fire bombed not all of them Joey
but some of them Joey you know there's
your dog don't get me out
for the neighborhood yeah [__] death
people have no idea all right
we had an interesting conversation a
couple weeks ago did you act eventually
go to Weight Watchers I didn't go to
Weight Watchers I should I we had a
great conversation I should try I want
to try people have had success with it
cuz I got all these photos I did say
knees I got all these [__] photos of
myself I don't want to look at all these
people who look good you know that's
very sweet that's also untrue but i
apprec--
but you know what it is when you're a
big guy it's all about the way the
camera hits you because when I when I
put myself on my jacket I look okay I
stop looking at myself in 1990 I'm like
all this [__] they're doing nobody's be
doing grandpa right oh yeah he'll is
grandpa you the amazing remembers
already because grandpa was a nut yeah
downstairs mixing chemicals yeah people
people forget how good of a show that
was when when bond the Carlo yeah used
to tell them grandpa put your fingers
off because he used to light his fingers
on fire yeah turn your fingers off there
was a thousand episodes that show yeah
well I laugh my ass off but that's not
the point it's just so weird how you and
I gotta tell you they all know it yeah
for the first time in the history of
entertainment the Entertainer has got
everybody by the ball that's true there
is no excuse to beat how back no more
agents it was about what color you are
what nationality you are I don't want to
hear none of your excuses I'm too fat
I'm too skinny I'm too ugly if you
really want it in today's world yeah all
you need is that [__] phone Twitter
Instagram YouTube yeah go to work till
the Empire do whatever you want to work
[__] got your money where your mouth
yeah
stop blaming it on yeah my agent doesn't
call me nobody calls me well you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of
younger guys I think in LA that there's
just this idea that they're you know oh
owed something like someone owes you
some and it's like growing up in New
York I would go to Broadway shows you
would walk by a black gospel church and
you would hear somebody on that stage
who was more talented than anybody
that's getting paid money to walk into
stadiums right now I mean just raw
talent raw natural talent you know I
would go to a Broadway show I'd see
somebody there was a play called a
ferryman that Jim gaff get told me to
see three-hour play I mean three hours
you know who's about Irish family about
a bunch of drunken DeGeneres I related
and it was just so good so good and
nobody and listen he's some of the
actors had careers but a lot of them no
one gives a [__] so coming from New York
you you realize that talent is isn't
always rewarded with anything but LA
because it's Hollywood and claw and
glaring people think that like they're
like hey I'm kind of half decent at this
where's my Maserati and the house in it
it's like what are you nuts like it
that's not what it is that's why I'm
happy then I came up in New York and I
kind of grew up there and I saw that
because it's like you realize talent
isn't enough you got a [__] hustle
because there's so many talented people
in New York to just they just atrophy
they fail you know but I should go too I
should go to Weight Watchers no I should
we were talking about and I was it was
just interesting because I I've for the
last 20 years as I moved to LA and
struggled with weight you know because
your focus is so much into comedy yeah
your focus is late-night eating as well
so there's not a lot of stuff that makes
you happy in life is not that's people
don't really nobody talks about that
there's just not a lot that makes you
happy
there's not you know it took me I knew I
didn't want to die from being a fat [__]
yeah that's why I don't I'd listen I
made decisions early on I didn't want to
get shot yeah I'm gonna die in the
prison okay I didn't want my girlfriend
finding me on the floor from an overdose
of cocaine and we're all gonna die from
a heart attack or smoking from this
reefer I've been smoked and all the
edibles or the pills we did fee is I
just didn't want to die from diabetes to
I didn't want to lose the [__] foot
right right okay I didn't want to go out
that way I'm gonna pick my pick I know
I'm gonna go out we all know we're gonna
go out right well pick your own way
you're gonna go out yeah okay do you
really want to go out in the [__] the
hospital you know because you [__]
didn't want to stop eating and our
burgers really right that's it you
[__] telling me that you want to go
out in the [__] Hospital
do you really want to have to pull up
your shirt once a [__] day yeah shoot
yourself in the [__] stomach crazy so
when you're on the road and whatever you
know I case or Ralphie may come in here
and I saw the lump on his neck from
whether that that [__] that gets Rory's
cortisol
was he that big for meeting no no he was
that big from [__] my skating it's
just hard to imagine like I know it's
what oh yeah rest in peace Ralphie May
right yeah it's great to be so Neil
yeah that's Western peace you know our
diets are not the best now and then we
had our sleep habits yeah that's bad too
to the diet and all that so you know by
2009 no I think 2007 I walked into way
watches I had the balls it was
embarrassing but I finally realized that
this was the best part of my week right
was gonna wait watches and [__] going
off like a lady started accepting it
like go off and then because going to
wait watch your meetings seem boring on
paper but they're very funny because
you're gonna start getting frustrated
because you're gonna see people that are
you right people that go I don't know
week every one of my me
they eat bananas and they still gained
eight pounds well you did something
wrong yeah yeah if you open at is every
meal and I walk my action points and I
still gained a pound yeah I want to
reach over and smack them right
there's people go and they'll actually
lose six ounces yeah like those say I
lost six ounces the last two weeks oh my
god you know there's people who go and
they gain weight and they'll go I could
do the food but I need my glass of wine
every night and you're like are you this
[__] still what he said it's the
system his points the system is point
and you based on your waiting and
everyone points your way you're ready
you can't you get points you get points
so you get 41 points a day okay I gotta
tell you you're 41 points a day then
they give you 50 action points in case
you go over the 41 now you look at me
going Joey watch 41 point ok 41 points
means that if I get six scrambled eggs
scramble them up pull Southside and put
black beans on and eat them that's zero
Wow that's zero
Wow if I take four chicken breasts and
put it on my grill and put salt and
pepper on them and whatever and get a
cup of white rice with red beans for
protein the other thing I'm paying for
is the rice the chicken and the beans
are free okay
seafood free piece of salmon would match
what about I had a lobster Benedict this
morning with on the English muffin with
the hollandaise side of cereal with your
berries almond milk and a little pastry
you done here's my question we had a
similar talk thinking does any of this
really work unless like you're ready to
lose weight no it works if we will know
what to you have to do read and write we
all know what you have to do but it's
just making the decision does it work if
you nothing works if you don't want
listen write nothing that you do has is
going to gain yet
results in crack no matter what you do
whether you play the flute whether you
[__] right you got to do it 100% you
got to either go on whatever then you
gotta don't do it at all
you know when I went into Weight
Watchers I wouldn't they reluctantly but
I kept an open mind and then I learned
it's not even a diet it's just a
lifestyle right okay so my breakfast
right now is one piece of wheat toast
two eggs and two pieces of bacon every
morning and I was sustained off that I
smoked weed yeah I smoked tons of weed
when I get up to make me eat those eggs
right but you know I know different
cheats right so give me a cheap but
thatís cool so two bananas and an apple
that's a cheat you know that's a little
cheap move to hold over you can't put
fruit into a [__] milkshake that'll
kill you right and make a protein shake
those protein shakes and I get two
points fight those eggs and I make a
protein shake it 11 I'm good till two
o'clock right I'm just buying time
you know I'm sad so are you doing and
then you learn how to eliminate to make
more points yeah like when I first
started drinking protein shakes I would
use 8 ounces of milk which is four
points or whatever the [__] it is 1/4
scoop of non sugar ice cream and the
protein powder so the protein shake was
essentially nine points right guess what
that protein shake is today two points
interesting I turn the milk into water
and still putting the ice cream in it
right and then I eliminated the [__]
ice cream so you can you can if you stay
on the points 41 points a day everyone
gets 41
no no everybody gets different according
your weight and then they give you fifty
five extra so right now it's [__]
Sunday I start again tomorrow
and I have right now I have 26 action
points left now what's an action point
that means I could do whatever the [__]
I want real means in reality my wife is
making chili for dinner I got seven
team points left I could eat those 17
points and I could go to Joe's pizza and
I have three slices oh my god because I
got till midnight to eat them
interesting and you're still on your
plan yeah yeah the thing with me is I'm
very light with it so I go between 290
and 294 I'm happy at that weight I can
die happy I would like to go down to 240
you know so that's the quad you get to
240 you didn't remember when I first
walked into a words that was 418 right
of course you know yeah and I was for 18
and then you just it's not a diet see
that's a it's a lifestyle see I did the
keto thing for a while it worked right I
think you know Chris I want you to do
something you're able to do on the road
every day that's hard that's where we
what yeah that's what I tell people yeah
well let's do the color would diet okay
so that means you're gonna eat a steak
for the rest of your [__] life three
times a day and a piece of salmon right
that's a good telling me right Janet
Jackson yeah that diets gonna work for
you right because what you get the same
ease and it's 1:00 in the morning it's
true what do you leave my surgeon okay
yeah I had three show Saturday night
between the second and the third show
it's like you got to do something I
didn't do is no food arrest right a
banana and four Oreos and two marlboro
lights and I you know I don't smoke but
I spoke occasionally and you know that
was my snack was put in four Oreos I've
been adding two marlboro lights and that
got me to the last show you know [__]
back I can take those 26 points my Anita
Oreos right go get Oreos how many points
of each Oreo and eat Oreos I drank time
I don't know once a week for six points
yeah yum yum donuts and
the [__] system so you get well into
the system could you know that's the
other thing how do you see what points
what is oh my god you go to a restaurant
they have it so I go to Weight Watchers
and say I'm going to PF Changs
right and they got the menu there oh wow
in-n-out burger like my celebration for
Weight Watchers like a four line fight
when I used to go to Weight Watchers in
that Hollywood my celebration was Monday
Sundays at 9:00 I would way I always
waited on a day I knew I was gonna be in
town I always way then you don't want to
weigh in on [__] Friday right oh
you're gonna go out Thursday night away
in front everybody know you and when you
walk in right you give the chickie
Claude you sign up for six months right
beep you give the chickie Claude you
it's like it's 19 fat people watching
everybody staring at you like you
[__] lied to us the computer the
scale and then show type it in I should
go you had a good week and then you buy
[__] sugar-free brownies or whatever
they have you always have snacks there
that I take on the road today good yeah
that's all I'd like well i and then
you'd learn how to prepare ten Dillon
you going to [__] Chicago this week
[__] now
you're gonna eat a beef and sausage sale
I feel it's so bad guess what but guess
what right but give me do me a favor for
Monday through Wednesday behave baby eat
the six eggs scrambled I don't give a
[__] eat the chicken breast get a salad
listen these people well if you're gonna
salad yeah right I'm sacrificing
everything right I'll take the five
points cuz I mean lettuce tomato onion
it's not that it's not the thing I was
when I nobody wakes up in the morning
this is you know what I think I'm gonna
have three [__] salads today because
I really want yeah I can't wait to get
my face done I can't wait to see how
that lettuces taste right right let's go
to dance
then anti-seize guys get the [__]
house out I like the Scala salad oh my
god the Skylar's got a good salad but
then you follow it up with this
spaghetti the cognac spaghetti with the
shrimp you gotta watch all that yeah I
know I'm sorry I saw the Danny Tanner
with my wife and everything is seafood I
opened up with I love sea so I fill up
on the seafood which everything is zero
right shrimp cocktails zero crab cakes
four points nothing yeah [__] fried
calamari is a killer right but that and
this and then I get the salad so by the
time the [__] steak comes you don't
even eat it I eat the steak I pay for
the points on the state yeah but I
filled myself up on the salad and the
shrimp cocktail right so it teaches you
how to [__] prepare for the week yeah
you know how you gonna go to New York
I'm not gonna eat a [__] egg roll
right okay only two egg rolls so in LA
from Monday through Wednesday right I'm
gonna be good at me it's like if I go to
New York I'm gonna eat a bagel would
like smokes 11:11 points yes I Hammond
is free okay but it's fish bingos 11
dorm only six yeah bagels a beast bagels
bagels a bad thing a big was like a half
a loaf of bread it's really bad for
bagels or 11 I love going this place I
get you know a cheese huh that 11 does
not include I do a fish spread that's
baked salmon a white fish political
Sables on the Upper East Side smoked
fish are fast and they put salmon
gravlax on it you know I mean it's you
tomato onion potato latke you throwing
their necessary quick all that [__] is
free like an efficient frame have you
noted and have you gained weight since
you've been in LA cuz I know I have you
walk along I've lost weight I was doing
really good and then the holidays came
and I went off the rails I went off the
rails I was doing really good I was
heading in the right direction and I and
then I went I went off the rails a
little bit because I was in New York for
a little bit over the holidays and it
just kind of Terrell a I was okay but
then New York you use a lot of carbs it
was a lot of friends I hadn't seen in a
while comedians everybody going out to
dinner let's go to dinner let's do
dinner you want to do
you'd be doing two dinners and I mean
you know you cuz we're out to 1:00 a.m.
do a comedy every night at 12:30 people
go let's go let's go to the diner and
now you're eating again you ate it it's
six or seven now you're eating again at
12:30 1:00 I mean it's just a recipe for
[__] disaster you know you don't go
out to a diner it did 12:30 at night to
order a you know chicken salad I mean
you order mozzarella sticks you gotten
you know a bacon egg and cheese sandwich
maybe you get now whatever you know
whatever grilled cheese bacon a tomato
french fries yeah I mean whatever it is
it's a problem my diner Mike to go diner
groan when I was living in [__]
Jersey yeah my to go diner was the
Berkshire diner and not one in there
especially on Wednesdays cream a turkey
soup ah that's great
well winter night turkey soup and
[__] winters you know we wouldn't
snort coke on Wednesday yeah you'd have
to respect for the Schumer 30 [__] I
thought strong Wednesdays did cream a
Turkey's a sleeper asleep it's a sleeper
if it's done well all my [__] it'll
change your life
and they had a thing I see this is the
reason I can't listen right now I'm
really much saved because ever since
Ralph he died it really woke my eyes up
like tomorrow I have to go to need
doctor at 11:30 see if I get some time I
throw this in my knees right another
thing with it you know you're young now
yeah when you're 55 and you're a comic
we climb a lot of stairs yeah how many
clubs ya walk a lot a lot of airports so
I've already had two knee surgeries and
tomorrow going further I this I love to
sit here and look in the eientei it's
because of my athletic performance
because you're a fat [__] right right
I'm a fat [__] so now they go deal with
this arts Riddick thing so that's why I
say to you started now yeah I'm 35 I got
started he want to start it I went to
Weight Watchers in my 40s and it was
phenomenal
I pee now that at 57 if I drink water I
gain weight really like I have to watch
everything yeah and I know that I do a
lot better like if I'm hungry now I do a
lot better if I eat a steak than if I
eat a banana
shake right like any sugar now I'm done
Sugar's the devil sugar destroys at my
age right now who Joey Diaz is today I
could if I take one of Mercy's candies
at night like if I walk by and think too
of a star bus I get on the scale the
next I've gained the pound right but I
could eat a steak and lose a [__]
pound right so these are the things you
learn by weighing yourself every day
lastly I was talking to somebody about
sleep how important a couple years ago I
loved Joe Rogan podcast
yeah I'm Stephen Tyler made me realize
how lazy you were right and I was 73
he's [__] doing and things that they
are killing it yeah but he had a guy on
there but sleep guys yeah watch that
sleep i watch that and that's part of
our problem we're not you know if we get
back at 1:00 that [__] in the old
days Tuesday through Sunday you have
five days of radio
you're gonna better three you're getting
up at 6 and radio right that destroy ya
or money so many aspects you know I saw
this this thing with Mick Jagger on
Netflix Olleh Olleh Olleh I love your
stolen fan and the guy asked him do you
are you upset that people mob you and
come up to you and ask you for pictures
and he goes right take being a better
friend to ourselves is also part of the
gig yeah I didn't know that I wanted a
broken why don't that level edition we
called using yeah I'm the first time he
called me and go let's go to the gym um
[Laughter]
yeah did yeah I was yeah we go will you
go on a road to do drugs to get STD
right and to [__] [__] people you
don't want the road to be healthy right
but he's amazing yeah he just helped
dissing after a while I watched them I
would avoid them yeah I started avoiding
them for breakfast right cuz he would
make me go to the gym and then go to eat
what's cool let's go eat yeah he's
eating eggs when I'd be on the [__]
treadmill Ryan
control weights or enough yeah yeah yeah
I think I do it like four times I'm like
I'm not going this long he said to me he
goes you guys just cut out carbs and
sugar I go oh but he's right here's the
thing he's always right it's just to say
to a guy like me cut out carbs sugar
it's a tough thing to do this is why I
like weight right right this is why I
could go on the road and eat honestly
right I love the hotel breakfast when I
get up cuz a couple whole meals five
points right and you should nice coffee
and you go back to bed like I said if
you if you asked a guy for a four egg
scrambled eggs with two pieces of wheat
toast your breakfast is two points right
so you could eat heavy for dinner and
you could that's why I like Weight
Watchers right cuz I'm not about carbs
it also forces you if you wanted to work
out and it has a meter and you could put
your points in there it's like this week
after kind of 48 workout points my goal
is 61 but I'm 57 years old of course and
heavy weights I go I went though I went
to a boxing class right I didn't go to
my Saturday class that I didn't feel too
good so I didn't want to go to Tempe
this week and have the flu right you go
to some of these schools and the [__]
doors are closed and people throwing
punches and you're like what the [__]
yeah it's flu season but it's cold that
way right so people don't open the doors
these weeks or I don't want that [__] so
I just worked out at home I get it I
want to go to your with you I want to go
to your meeting wherever your meeting is
I want cuz I'll go to that now I go to
meetings when I go in Studio City yeah
I'm gonna check I want to check down day
night six I want to check that out the
next Monday I don't think do [__]
words there yeah I'm not gonna say
anything did learn you and you learned
I just want to observe and see what this
thing is go online I have such an
aversion to cults and I know they say I
know it's not a call I know it's not a
call but when I did Weight Watchers I
think these fat women in the suburbs who
a full-of-shit like my mother and her
friends were like you can eat whatever
you want but you got to be accountable
and
would never you know and it never made
me sad thinking about my fat aunt being
like I can eat cake but then I just have
to have water like that's not out
weren't you idiot but I want to see it
and observe it and see what it is
accountability is everything it's really
telling you it's like you telling me the
answer is thirty seven rats great show
me to work right and that's why that's
why I enjoy it because yeah I'm a count
I like being accountant yeah if you go
to my house right now or you go to my
office there's a little notebook with
Monday through Friday Monday through
Sunday you creep do you pre cook any of
the meals or did you lose weight when
you were single joy yeah was it harder
no okay it's all the same
yeah it's called pushing yourself away
from the table that's true I was an
expression they used in Jersey yeah the
push yourself away from the best
exercise there's no single no married no
not right if you want to get help you
push yourself away from the [__] tape
hundreds to call it two things when I
was growing up Flushing it's time for
you to flush yeah that meant you get a
little big yeah I threw the flush yeah
and that managed to get like four pounds
and it's time for you to push yourself
away from the table yeah you know I love
food you know but I avoid desserts
I got took my wife you having food the
other night yeah I got the fried bananas
I got the pork junks I paid for them
you got to pay for them right so I li
like fish for lunch right and I had
yogurt with fruit for breakfast right
bad for that right so I prepared for
that you know I don't want to die in the
hotel room G now and some [__] town
yeah you know I would New York yeah that
means being from New York yeah I bust
people's I must be pushed balls that
muscle these balls about would dead up
here after nine o'clock yeah happy right
I'm kind of happy that would that appear
after nine o'clock yeah I can't go get a
[__] open space
that's good with onion ring you can't do
that in New York so easily you know and
the other cheeseburger the lucky
the [__] gravy yeah you get it all I
get it all I'm what surround cheese get
anything you want I'm gonna just go home
to die right nice la there's no room one
day you get a sandwich in New York at
3:00 in the morning a beautiful turkey
sandwich with everything and you know
chips and stuff and then you can't do
that no you can't do it which is good
I've got to I'm happy because one night
did you about Joe Diaz what happened
well [__] he had a heart attack last
night come on I was we dropped them off
at 3:30 yeah we went to eat yeah yeah
that's what he died you a date yeah
where'd you go we know one for steak
sandwiches other diamond yeah we got the
whole extra order of [__] steak fries
yeah then we got them because I used to
get a milkshake yeah there was a time
when I would get the cup of the bowl of
turkey soup this isn't this is when I
was 20 oh yeah I would get the bowl of
turkey soup the Opus Dei salad I mean is
there anything better than that it's
really not one garlic roll or some
garlic bread with a little butter on
yeah it's just a yeah there's nothing
big nice then you get them [__] yeah
the mozzarella cheese yeah grazie yeah
but they brown the cheese yeah bring me
a soda the whole time you're drinking a
coke yeah [__] water I didn't drink
water top ten years I swear to God I
didn't drink this [__] don't thank me
the one thing you're one reason I'm
alive is I don't drink soda I think
that's one reason I'm okay guys I don't
drinks I don't like anything with
bubbles so I don't drink soda that's my
thing and I don't really eat like you
know I don't eat [__] like chips and
candy and garbage I don't really fast
food but I do but I will eat food I will
eat a bowl of pasta I will eat a dessert
I will eat something I shouldn't eat but
I don't eat like chips and snacks
there's no snacks it's not none of that
[__] there's no salty snacky [__]
but if I go out you know I love bread I
love seafood but there's something about
seafood and bread you go to rest they
put the shrimp cocktail on the table and
they put the crab cocktail on a table
and a nice warm loaf of bread I feel
like I'm [__] god I just got off a
boat I'm just eating the bread and
eating it I don't know what it is but
there's some
about that combination it's great and
then you know then you like oh [__] you
know why I like Weight Watchers also I
was watching Tom pop on Conan yeah about
14 16 months ago yeah and he just got
into making bread yeah he makes a lot of
bread he makes great bread and he
brought a loaf in here one day and he
said something he goes you know what man
I think that at times our country is uh
has forgotten that we'll put on this
planet to have a good time right you
know it's okay to eat that piece of
bread right when I go to Dan Tana's or
whatever yeah I don't need a piece of
bread right I just prepared for it
pretty damn sure I go to kickbox in that
morning right I do something to earn it
yeah it's make sense oh man and you feel
better about it you feel better about
yeah yeah nobody's telling you not to
live that's the other thing that I don't
like like that I don't like anything
look I'm gonna be a juicer what do you
wanna do when you in Syracuse New York
yeah you know what is the one you were
[__] tell me where they'll have juice
right these people I live with my first
got into comedy would you started
juicing and they'd used to do meth and
then they started juicing and they did
it the same way they didn't I said you
go back to math because this is
discussing they drink warm disgusting
foamy juices and that you guys don't
want you to live right you know what's
my birthday to wish you don't think I'm
getting a carve-out cake fudgie the
whale and me him his brother ate a whole
fudgie the whale ones you don't think
I'm gonna [__] get a Carvel cake yeah
celebrate it's the back I'm dead it's
the best I can't afford
yeah yeah you one piece of right well
points yeah Carvel cakes twelve points
for a little tiny son we're gonna get
one in the car on the way all we're
gonna eat it the car you're not gonna
budge either will how many points is
that best [__] set you off women
gays I was in Brooklyn last year are you
sure you yeah this is just I was in
Brooklyn last year shooting a surprise
yeah and I mean they told us that we
were gonna be in this one area for a
week and with Drive and you know
everybody's Drive and look at that going
oh look at the Verrazano Bridge
everybody's looking like that you know
it's like I said yeah yeah Taurus some
people go to New York Taurus to look at
some [__] yeah
others of us go to New York right make a
memory fudgie the whale look what I took
a picture of look at this [__]
place
yeah there's valves in Brookside Avenue
and Queens is so beautiful look at that
place beautiful no I'm trying to explain
to him it's the best ice cream I
understand it's the best - soft-serve is
the best look look at this look at that
flying saucers there's one Carvel in LA
it's in Santa Monica yes yes one yeah I
know at one time so they charged me 450
for the cone yeah you understand that
one day I said they're waiting to shoot
I'm there for like three hours like Jo
bumpy in my trailer
yeah why not cause I go you know what
it's time to smoke a joint it was like
4:30 yeah they came in there like us you
telling me yeah I know the [__] joint
I swear to god guys I walk out of my
trailer I look I see The Sopranos makeup
trailer [__] and there's a busy street
there's like one Street you have the
cloth and then like 50 steps and you're
on the Main Street I don't give a [__]
it's Brooklyn it's 4:30 in the afternoon
I sparked this joint I take a hit off
and then look to the corner and it's
like God presently there was a Carvel on
the corner that one that second one not
too old for a 1940 yeah the new one a
new one
I was like Jesus
I smoked that joint like a little
[__] kid that they like yeah it felt
like I was just let out of prison yeah
just smoke this joint too long before I
had my soprano Sudan yeah yeah I walked
down Brookdale [__] haven't already
and I walked in there I saw the [__]
the Flying Saucer yeah I got the flying
sauces and the lady says to me hi can I
help you she was Chinese the whole
family with China a lot did they buy the
car bells change very smart
no two daughters will work yeah it's a
very kind of culture the girl goes what
uh what are you looking for I go I want
a chocolate milkshake thin ice she goes
what size I go come on give me the and
before I said then I go hold on one
second and I pressed in [__] it won't
come in here coz the computer's not
working the internet will never work in
here but I pressed in [__] Carvel I
always do a vanilla milkshake with
chocolates here big crunchies Oh swirled
through it oh my god and I tell her I go
swirl the crunchies through and it's
it's phenomenal oh my god bastard didn't
like I looked at that what I told her
give me the large before I send large I
look down I think it was 34 so that's
your that's your day I remember give me
a medium yeah I gave me a medium and I
didn't want to swell up for the camera
yeah 25 I basically took it outside did
this and I just threw it in the garbage
I've died away from me I've done that in
ships I've done that in there were like
I've taken a cone bought it done like
three or four big big bite to the cone
and thrown it out cuz I also had a
milkshake like I wanted balls to get me
a double cone yes and the chocolate
shake yes I would do and then that's a
real [__] fat pig yes I would dump
the cone into the milk right let me take
that's when you're a fat yes gusting
that's bad yeah that's why one
I had one day I walked out of Carvel
I had cuz it was through his Sunday day
and they go we if you buy a thing you
get a free set so I'm like okay and I
walk out with one color one Sunday I'm
dunking the cone in the sundae and
eating it and my friend who's outside
rolls the window down and he goes this
is bad and we started we both started
laughing we looked each other we both
started laughing so hard where I start
laugh thought it was crying
do you know you're a fat [__] yeah when
you get Sunday and they don't have your
[__] p.m. helmet and you don't give a
[__] right yeah what do you have we have
but that [__] grew oh I grew up like you
know my parents were like boomers and we
were fast food generation of kids so
like we grew up on McKee and I remember
why I used to be a swimmer when I was a
kid I was like an athlete from when I
was like 6 years old to like 11 or 12
every morning you know they you know on
the weekend we had long course in
Freeport Long Island my father got me
out of bed because my mother was a swim
coach you drive me today and it was an
Olympic sized pool and it was freezing
and it threw you in the pool and you
swam your ass off her for an hour and an
hour an hour and a half practice swam
your ass off these coaches would scream
at your head down go go go go and then
after that we go to McDonald's for
breakfast and this is this is the
mistake you know my parents made you
know after that I've got to McDonald's
for breakfast like get a bacon egg and
cheese biscuit and hotcakes and I would
eat both of those steaks and I
remembered and you felt good because you
just swam your ass off and the reward
was yet that that flaky bacon egg and
cheese biscuit and and the hotcakes
McDonald's has the best pancakes for
fast food pancakes no nobody you know
and then that was like that was do I
remember after I swam on my swam a mile
when I was six years old in the bay and
this was like a big thing on my town
they had races every summer and I swam a
mile after that my mother took me and
four other kids they were all older but
they'd swam a - we went to this ice
cream parlor in Valley Stream call
Ekans and they had the socket to me
sunday it was just 14 scoops ice cream
and every [__] thing that had into
place and they just threw it all in a
[__] ball and they just ate they slid
it on a table at me and he's four other
kids just went a little bit that's how
we grew up going you did something good
here's food here's food here's a bowl of
ice cream
here's pancakes you know my grandmother
was Irish woman who learned how to make
meatballs in Brooklyn from an Italian
lady so my grandmother made the best
meatballs in the world you know and and
you know it was one of those things
where like when she had a pot of
Meatballs the family liked each other
and I'm from an Irish Catholic family of
alcoholics you know so but when they
were meatballs on the stove everybody
was like let's put it to bed for today
we can fight tomorrow we can fight about
whose fault it is we don't have the
mortgage tomorrow today we got me so
food to me was always like and then my
uncle was a director of operations for a
big steak house group in New York City
Smith and Wollensky 's all these big
steak houses someone as a little kid you
know we weren't we were lower
middle-class but we got to go to these
really nice New York City restaurants
and eat the shrimp cocktail and the rib
eyes and like you got to see all this
real good food and then so to me going
out to dinner became like the [__]
luxury item cuz that's when you're poor
your luxury items a nice meal I can't
buy a Maserati I can't go out and get a
house in Malibu but I can go get a nice
dinner so the whole thing it's you know
you integrated into your life is like a
thing you know and it's it has
psychological components to you know the
whole thing it's very weird what we do
Tim Dylan listen man it's been a real
pleasure thank you I've been watching
you're gonna go gonna [__] I went to got
them a couple years ago and heard your
name and then I remember I think
Stanhope retweeted something of yours
yeah yeah yeah and then I heard you were
moving Holly and you've done everything
perfectly you I appreciated your on the
conveyor
belt I like to tell you I appreciate
that said matter of whatever the [__]
you ready yeah blow the [__] I
appreciate it thank you you made me
laugh my ass off today yeah I've never
seen nobody else get excited as Karvelas
I think you and I are the only ones that
take pictures away the only one to take
pictures on by the book yeah like my
wife always say oh yeah we're gonna buy
this cake from yeah yeah it's fine
right we're still getting the carb okay
we get ice cream there's nothing better
after a party than a Carville ice cream
cake nothing nothing there's nothing you
know that's uh I went that I was very
excited again I'm a fat [__] yeah I was
here when there was a sad Brett truck in
front of sag oh I was wrongly customer
oh that's you'd be out there smoking
Marlboro Red nothing's on a prick see
that yeah that's funny I would spend $35
yeah over 450 apiece right because you
got to ship them out here yeah it's a
whole thing
so I still remember going in sad Brett
dogs I'm you know and I still remember
them going there's a rumor in LA what
Carvel's coming to town and I remember
getting my car and driving all the way
there Oh Louis Century City what does it
call Avenue the Americas
yeah I've been pulling in there happy as
a pig in [__] and walking in there and
getting up another cone just to try it
yeah you know me said I'm not gonna go
and then go all out right and then
realize this guy's a [__] Chinook
right and I realize he what's a Chinook
yeah I realized the cones were 450 yeah
and it was an investment he didn't
really love carve out like now so uh
it's an Indian lady in there now she's a
little better in Santa Monica
yeah you get a little coppery queen up
here in the middle is that guy from Long
Island baseball team a hundred percent
see I don't care the pedophile other way
to matter he's got a love carve-out he
makes the cake the right actual
assailant with his keys keeping his
powder dry I'll take my daughter in them
all right I think my daughter in there
don't even know what he's doing he's
fine I'm making me a LOX come right
right New York and what you need it from
you
Gilbert right I wouldn't buy a lot when
I first moved to the valley my wife and
I didn't have a child and Friday nights
was date night and we would go out and
lurk into the valley and one night I'm
no [__] Internet my wife found the
Dairy Queen we didn't know that there
was one in Burbank
yeah in the mall but there's one you
gotta drive like a [__] 45 minutes
for that and I remember going up there
and they were foreigners and I got very
insulted because I knew was an
investment it wasn't something that they
grew up saying I want to buy a Carvel
right like I want to buy a car I'd be
ten or would be broke yeah and I'd be a
I'd be you know I would die Brian I
would love I could tell you I don't have
a crystal ball but I can tell you what
I'd look like if I had a car boy I have
one of those little bicycles yeah you'll
be on a scooter yeah with a too big my
nose yeah between the reefer and the
yeah I just [__] killed my foot
yourself in a coma yeah that's it I
would be I would put myself on the
kulluk I would call wait watch them to
listen give me a point system dedicated
around three meals around Carvel yeah
yeah like three ounces of vanilla ice
cream for breakfast in syrup that that
[__] is like you can't you can have it
every now and then like who like like a
few times a year you know because that
type of points you can't you can't just
that can't be right
sherry died of a heart attack but both
and let me know it's like one of the ice
cream stores they died of heart attacks
but benaderet still life yeah I think
they're silly um yeah they're all going
that way they're all going that way well
hey I'm gonna hit up a meeting with your
Monday one one Monday
let's go just for I want to observe I'd
like to go to your Weight Watchers me
okay you go on Monday its Mondays at
6:00
okay yellow means very light where do
you live I'm a West Hollywood a few
blocks from the comics but I would also
love for you to do me a favor yeah I go
there yeah for you to go to you know you
go when you type in zip code
yeah and it tells you the closest one I
want you to hit the ten o'clock yeah in
Hollywood and listen well on Days our
process was we go if we lost weight me
and Rick Ramos we were partners yeah he
was my partner in it so it's a lot
better if you have a friend go when you
make a deal with them right if we both
lost weight we were allowed to stop in
and out right because we get out of a
meeting at 11:00 there's nobody there
now right right there and Hollywood
right here by the show Hollywood yeah so
I would we would go then get a single
you're allowed to get a single
cheeseburger with half order fries to
die coca 15 points so we would split a
[__] order of fries get a one patty
cheeseburger and split a tie and each
get a diet coke right that was our
reward reward yeah and also it was
always a reward even if we lost a pound
we went in and out [__] it put it down
to our points right but it was since you
talked to me I wanted to talk to you
about it buddy
when you may find your brother Tim Jay
Dylan uh di ll o N on Instagram shame
handle on Twitter Tim Dylan comedy calm
is on my live dates or we're announcing
a tour you know you know I think this
week coming up like a 35 city tour very
busy this 2020 I'll be all over the
place come back and promote please yeah
Tim Dylan show we is my podcast on Apple
and YouTube and everywhere hi Clark
after you do a week I do one for patreon
and then I do one
or you know it goes out every Sunday for
everybody and then you still do the
crazy videos oh yeah we do them all the
time you got one coming out really soon
yeah we should be really fun and yeah we
do and we do like one a week we're
trying to do one a week sometimes they
pop big sometimes they just say you know
it's gonna call following but we see
what happens
I appreciate you take not I appreciate
you taking the time thank you so much
you're doing it right you Andrew Schultz
is apart there's a handful of you
[__] that I'm looking at here
and she's reading you nothing but
success but I don't have to wish why I
was because you guys did that and paved
the way for [__] guys I got so I
appreciate we're all criminals yeah well
I appreciate I just kept getting onstage
yeah the way it is you know all you guys
do everybody try to buy YouTube friends
yeah get onstage I just wanted make
enough money to open up a mortgage
brokerage no no no men you can open up a
car bell weed shop suicide fudgie the
gun up yeah not even a [__] feels as
good T as a Carvel [__] nothing's better
435i appreciate just drop you off at the
[__] low non-athletic way up there by
that Islip [__] Airport one flight
there it goes every day to Disney World
takes a bunch of fat long and a [__] at
Disney World
that's what the whole reason the airport
is open all right thank you so much
Johnny thank you very much listen I want
to tell you don't forget Tempe this
weekend
all that's available is Thursday night
you [__] up Thursday night now 10
o'clock that's all you got
and then the I'm a Treasure Island the
27th of February with my man Dean del R
is if the church is also brought to you
by on it right now I think they're still
running it if you buy alpha brain
whether you buy the packages or the
[__] container 30 or the 90k
you get a raffle ticket to win the on it
experience go to alikom right now I live
on the [__] the whatever the immune
and the shroom tech sport and I love all
that stuff to see TM the CTM the coconut
for your coffee mcc CMT whatever the
[__] it is listen as far as something
that's gonna turn on is the one I can't
help you with the way to the club bats
but supplements I got you covered go to
Hana calm right now I'm press in church
BAM CH you are CH and get 10% off on
your next delivery delivered right to
your [__] door listen do me a
favor have a great Monday
see you guys Wednesday at Thursday the
rest of you [__] I'll see you
Thursday night at The Improv in Tempe
stay black I love you and have a great
day thank you Tim Dylan thank you thank
you Christ killer uncle Joey slashing
out of this [__] I gotta take
two steps to the rear and get out of
here later